girls always sing songs and they think
that it's empowering and it just makes
you sound [ __ ] stupid okay it's just
something about it like from the very
beginning like remember what are these
dumb songs you know yeah rude and [ __ ]
you with your old tired girlfriend she
come over to finance don't you wish
young girlfriend why you gotta be like
this I got all this right here that's
[ __ ] up you know they have Beyonce -
we got set her on fire just set on fire
now it's all her songs just like we were
just
[ __ ] did you pay my bills
Michigan's specific pay my telephone
beer now you pay in this bitch's bills
does she think you cheating on her Suzy
like say my name say my name when no one
is around you Beyonce Beyonce yeah what
the [ __ ] does that even mean I don't get
it you try to hit it I don't think you
ready for this I'm ready for the jelly
I'm paying your bills
remember - Erica I'm gonna be a [ __ ]
that's the ability equal jelly it's a
real simple ass equation
[Applause]
what not you independent this [ __ ] is
[ __ ] bananas okay I'm paying her
bills now she famous I live in her house
now she bought me a car and clothes now
she think I'm cheating on her left
everything you own in a box to let me
tell you why that's the stupidest one
ever ladies if all your man stuff can
fit in a box he ain't [ __ ] anyway do you
see how stupid that is like she's you
know she's talked about how she bought
him a car and all this [ __ ] he's
replaceable that was replaceable is [ __ ]
she's not talking about jay-z okay that
[ __ ] right now
jay-z's box is full of [ __ ] you know Sam
Sam you got diamonds I got my box [ __ ]
bye so now I'm in this taxi cab on the
way to my mama's house with this box in
my lap you call her up come on you know
I love you why you doing this to me
work [ __ ] ever happened to me am i uh
this is the six-week anniversary of this
all right I was flying to Washington and
to do next to me [ __ ] his pants
yeah
and it wasn't like well you would be
like oh my god you can have some apathy
in this doing this might go like uh like
the nougat maybe like oh good you know
because he didn't know you know so this
smell was wafted up to me every 15
[ __ ] minutes
and when you smell that you're like and
it wasn't a fart because we all know
what a fart farts have a tinge in sa
quoi if I may we know what a fart in a
minute where you are in the world so my
fart you can be like somebody farted who
farted this was like between fart and
open baby diaper it was like you know
and now I'm getting mad cuz this dude
shitty pants over here I got the credit
card application I'm coming to black
church man you know shitty man sees me
doing this and he goes are you okay I
don't know there's some kind of like
flatulence situation I didn't want to be
crass on the plane so I said collector
Lynch and he goes on it's too bad he
turns his thing on a pointed at me okay
two hours later shitty pants gets up to
go to the bathroom it turns to Canon
towards me
that's when I knew that I don't wanna
[ __ ] his pants now he's walking back to
the [ __ ] crop dusting the whole plane
now when he came back to his seat at
that moment he knew he [ __ ] his man
and he knew that I knew he [ __ ] his man
so I was giving him the you [ __ ] your
pants face how are we doing over here
man make matters worse I tell my mom
about it right get off the planet Oh mom
the dude next to me [ __ ] his pants my
mom's you know what your mother says
[ __ ] to you that you just want to like
set her on fire
talk about no sympathy she says well
what did the airline deal mom there's no
[ __ ] your pants run along
it's not doing the safety talk where
they like you know emergency exits are
here in the event you [ __ ] your man I
swear to you she thought the captain was
gonna be late
she kept it you an emergency situation
8b has [ __ ] his hand I'm gonna take her
down to Toledo
we're just really stupid we're dumb
as human beings were dumb I mean when we
come out the womb we're done we can't do
[ __ ] for like 12 13 years we literally
can't do anything antelope come out of
the womb like this come on [ __ ] there's
lions we we cut us we can't we don't
even come out we have to be pulled out
we're pretty dumb and then now I'll
check this out too
in modern times right now you have to go
to school for 20 years before you're
considered smart a master at something
20 years another five if you want your
PhD do you know the life expectancy of
the people that wrote the Bible
it's like 30-ish how smart could they be
[Applause]
I'm just throwing it out you know we
just think you know we need we have
stories to help us understand [ __ ]
the Bible is missing one sentence on the
cover based off true events hey when you
when you see a movie that says based on
true events what does that tell you wow
this is probably [ __ ] I mean the
ship sank but there wasn't a dude in the
front going King in a world that's
called embellishment we embellished the
mythology so we can help ourselves
understand but it doesn't mean it
actually happen like that
see Bible people get mad at me cuz they
think Noah was standing in front of a
boat with the clipboard like this let's
get started
red ants welcome aboard
black ants everywhere you go there's
some skinny person rubbing it in your
face I was with my mom went to church
with my mom and that big Jesus was on
the cross and he's just rid of just he's
up there show it all
sometimes he hit you with the head tilt
away Jesus is in shape but you can't
have a fad Jesus dad
I mean fat Jesus would changing the
whole story
I mean imagine you put 250 pounds on any
story it's gonna be different
you know I mean I mean imagine the
logistics of trying to get fat Jesus on
the cross you got to have a rope and
pulley system there trying to nail me
slide down all the miracles will be
different he's walking on water
waist-deep of your Lord the Last Supper
would be a buffet you know Judas would
be at the buffet going really really
Jesus it's a lot of rats you putting on
that lamb hotels when I travel though I
like that though [ __ ] on the ground
would just be like cold clean servants
[Laughter]
but I like staying there hotels there's
two things about hotels though that
drive me bananas the first one is why is
there a full-length mirror
facing my toilet why is that I don't I
don't get that I know you never notice
it till you sit down so that you get
keep trying to grab towels to cover
yourself because you that you look over
there's a coffee pot on the counter a
coffee pot I'm [ __ ] in here
shitty who's making hot beverages in the
bathroom [ __ ] annoying you know and
the other one is you know when you're
checking into a hotel you ever wonder
what in the [ __ ] are they typing on the
computer that's taking so long
you have my reservation but you know I'm
coming what's going on here you give him
your name in there back there
Shelagh when you check people in is it
m6 you look good let's talk it much [ __ ]
what's your last name sir it's like are
you real live in a satellite back there
I was in this documentary is called just
like us it's about American comics
performing in the Middle East it was on
like Showtime right if you guys ever saw
it but anyway it was very interesting
but one of the things I remember about
the Middle East that I people don't they
think they know but you don't really
know how absolutely anti-semitic it is
in the Middle East like awesome on other
level [ __ ] like no matter what is
happening it's like it could be raining
and somebody be like what the Jews and
it's like we're like casual conversation
to like somebody could be walking just
be like oh god damn Jews don't like Jews
I don't like gays for some reason like
you know it's very homophobic you know
but the strange thing is they like to
hold hands like guys hold hands this is
real [ __ ] okay I'm in the Middle East
and I dudes are holding pinkies they
hold pinkies it is like that's a gateway
to suck a dick that's not
you hold a piggy
right after you just like come here haha
isn't the movie theater the one place
you're not supposed to take a baby like
you know that man like yes
spider-man's out but you don't get to
see it you wanted to have a baby that's
now your life when your comic on the
road you you go what you see a lot of
movies I saw two movies in Texas one
movie the woman shushing the baby the
whole [ __ ] movie and the second one
was like this one was breastfeeding
breastfeeding in the movie theater you
know how I know this is all I heard
[Laughter]
[Music]
you are tearing that titty up then her
cell phone was going off and can we just
be honest is it vibrate a ringtone she
doesn't hear her phone excuse me man
that's your phone it was in the
cupholder
I thought the security was gonna be a
lot stricter you know like let's say
this is the computer that the dude is
supposed to be looking at when your bags
are going through this is him go
[Applause]
what that what are you doing go put on
your shoes and go you know hey what the
[ __ ] is going on here
it's no rules over there I'll tell you
like when you when the plane lands here
in the United States - plane lands they
say please keep your seats wait you get
to the gate not in the Middle East like
that so there's a plane hits down people
are up like just trying to get their bad
cigarettes are being lit like I'll tell
you listen we I take the weirdest thing
I was in Syria I went to Syria and like
okay one person like you made it out you
know I tell you what freaked me out is
like like they really do not like Jews
okay
like people who own a lot of people in
the Middle East they don't like Jews on
a level that's like so casual like you
had a party just talking to somebody and
you're like man it's raining well did
yous wait what what I don't understand
so I be walking down the street oh oh
the Jews
the Jews some hateful [ __ ] man
they're like Jews and they don't think
gays exist in the Middle East you know
you people where the Middle East thing
is like it doesn't really exist even
though grown-ass men will hold pinkies
and walk down the street like this have
you ever seen that I just grown men
burly men like me just walking down the
street this is a gateway to sucking dick
you understand that before use like a
big ego and the weirdest thing to me to
those for a place that hates gays they
are obsessed with a clean butthole I'm
not being dirty ma'am at all I'm just
saying at the in the bathroom in every
Middle Eastern country there's a
high-powered water hose right next to
every bathroom and I'm not talking about
that [ __ ] you clean the dishes with no
no no this could take paint off a
battleship okay you know so I should a
half cocked it you know I mean nobody
told me so I gave it a fool the Jews the
Jews did this right here just the Jews
the Jews put that in here I'll tell you
that right now something refreshing
though knowing that everybody had a
clean butthole
that's definitely refreshing you could
just walk around and do a spot butthole
check baho check go you know Middle East
has clean buttholes underarms and breath
on fire
[Music]